bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 13 novembre du 7 8 sur téléphiles 78
en direct si vous nous suivez à 18h
première invitée pour débuter cette
édition guillaume pas ce qui est bon
soir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
général de l'établissement public paris
saclay et vous allez nous en dire plus
sur vos missions et surtout sur l'avenir
de ce dossier dont on parle déjà depuis
plusieurs années faut-il craindre que sa
réalisation ce soit difficile crise ou
pas le premier ministre en tout cas
confirmé son soutien c'était il y a
quelques semaines tout juste quinze
jours on reviendra sur ses déclarations
le mardi il est aussi une question
d'environnement la chronique
environnement avec valérie auribeau
bonsoir valérie et ce soir vous allez
nous parler du bio oui de la filière
céréalière et plus particulièrement de
la farine bio avec l'un des dernier
meunier traditionnel yvelinois qui sera
avec nous sur ce plateau nous verrons
également comment il travaille on verra
des images de son exploitation ce sera
la chronique environnement comme chaque
mardi dans le set suite et puis ce soit
en nous parlerons aussi l'aide de ses
salariés qui donne une journée de leur
temps de travail pour une action de
solidarité une initiative de la société
holcim à saint quentin en yvelines une
quarantaine de collaborateurs à nettoyer
les abords de l'étang dénouer à la
verrière le chef de projet sera sur ce
plateau c'est l'image du jour la
rencontre de la ministre délégué chargé
des personnes handicapées marie-arlette
carlotti avec être des responsables de
thales à elancourt une visite sur le
terrain ce matin avant le discours
prononcé dans la soirée à paris lors
d'une réunion du réseau économique de la
pf l'association des paralysés de france
en cette semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées marie-arlette
carlotti ministre délégué en charge des
personnes handicapées s'est rendu
aujourd'hui à elancourt au sein de
l'entreprise thales mais j'ai vu une
entreprise où il y avait véritablement
une volonté claire affirmé depuis 20 ans
d'intégrer les personnes en situation de
handicap comme des travailleurs
ordinaires avec leurs difficultés avec
intégré garder dans l'emploi maintenir
dans l'emploi quand il s'agit de
salariés à qui il est arrivé
blême de maladie ou garder dans l'emploi
depuis 20 ans le groupe thales mène une
politique d'insertion à l'égard des
personnes en situation de handicap
aujourd'hui le taux global d'emplois
réservés aux personnes handicapées
s'élève à 5,1 pour cent et concerne 1640
salariés le groupe espère atteindre
d'ici à la fin de l'année le taux
minimal de 6 % imposée par l'état il est
important que cette compétence elle
reste dans l'entreprise et c'est pas
parce que c'est une personne handicapée
qu'elle ne doit pas avoir une évolution
de carrière comme les autres afin qu'on
puisse garder aussi cette compétence est
donc c'est en mettant en place et ses
politiques de maintien dans l'emploi
donc accompagnement adaptation des
postes de travail innovation
technologique aussi pour permettre de
mettre en place des moyens techniques
pour compenser le handicap et puis des
formations appropriées qu'on arrive à
maintenir dans l'emploi des personnes
handicapées à l'exemple de ses salariés
qui bénéficient d'une aide technique
pour leur permettre de mieux voir ou de
communiquer par téléphone malgré un
handicap auditif vous le savez
le président d'un public qui va
s'exprimer tout à l'heure le premier
ministre a comme objectif l'emploi
l'emploi est toujours l'emploi on parle
beaucoup du rééquilibrage des comptes
publics la situation compliquée c'est
vrai que c'est pas quelque chose qui
fait rêver mais derrière ça nous
n'oublions pas notre objectif la justice
la solidarité et ça passe par l'emploi
et ça passe par l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap le président
république de sa campagne a dit qu'il
augmenterait les sanctions des
entreprises qui ne répondent pas aux
critères de la loi mais pour y remédier
en même temps qu augmenter les sanctions
on va d'abord discuter et c'est bien ce
qu'on va faire en 2013 lors d'une vraie
négociation avec l'ensemble des
partenaires autour de la table de son
côté l'ump a lancé une pétition visant à
accorder un prêt à taux zéro pour les
personnes souffrant d'un handicap moteur
la proposition de loi menée par gérald
darmanin et l'illinois david douillet
est déjà soutenue par 103 députés
nous allons consacrer le décryptage de
ce soir de cette édition du 13 novembre
au grand paris avec le directeur général
de l'établissement public paris-saclay
votre mission c'est de développer le
sud-ouest de paris un plateau qui
principalement agricoles qui est bordée
par la bièvre par liv est ce assez pour
les précisions géographiques et quand on
cherche un petit peu plus à définir vos
missions voilà ce qu'on peut retrouver
contribuer à une croissance équilibrée
du territoire et à sa contribution à
l'attractivité francilienne et française
c'est à dire pour les non initiés alors
pour les non initiés en quelques mots
effectivement rappelons ce que c'est que
ce grand projet paris saclay vous l'avez
dit c'est un projet du grand paris ça
fait partie du grand paris et c'est en
réalité un triple projet dans
l'établissement public a la charge ou du
moins auquel ils contribuent à premier
projet un projet universitaire
technologique scientifique avec sur ce
territoire l'autre spécificité celle que
vous n'avez pas cité c'est une
concentration exceptionnelle de
potentiel scientifique et technologique
qui sont arrivés au cours de l'histoire
au cours des 50 dernières dernières
années avec le cea avec l'école
polytechnique il existe déjà des choses
idiotes l'assaut des gérants n'est pas
aujourd'hui nous avons déjà sur ce grand
territoire que vous avez dont vous avez
bien délimitées 13% à peu près de la
recherche publique française
le dernier arrivé est en l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin plus plus plus
récemment et je dis bien aujourd'hui
c'est à dire l'équivalent de tout ce
qu'on trouve dans dans la région
rhône-alpes dans son ensemble donc le
premier projet i les scientifiques
c'est-à-dire de renforcer ce potentiel
en accueillant de nouvelles écoles de
nouveaux établissements qui veulent
rejoindre qui veulent rejoindre ce grand
pôle et qui veulent s'organiser de façon
un petit peu révolutionnaire en une
grande université de paris saclay qui
regroupera des universités parions le
musée excuse j'ai cité des grandes
écoles d'ingénieurs prestigieuses
polytechnique centrale l'agro etc et des
centres de recherche comme le cea comme
le cnrs cominar tout cela fait un
ensemble exceptionnel c'est la première
dimension du projet deuxième dimension
du projet dimension économique
l'ambition c'est de tirer profit au
maximum de cette concentration pour
déclencher de la delà de l'innovation de
la croissance économique
création de petites entreprises issues
de ces labos
multiplient croissance des pme
technologiques déjà présentes et puis
atrax attractivité auprès des grands
groupes et de leurs erreurs au centre de
recherche c'est la deuxième dimension et
la justice sur le fait le campus c'est
essentiellement en fait un territoire
assez restreint au sud de ce plateau
l'actra tibet que l'attractivité
économique ça va beaucoup plus loin il
ya bien sûr les entreprises qui sont
juste à côté des labos et puis il ya
celles qui sont dans cette ce grand
archipel de zones de zones d'activités
qui est autour qui est particulièrement
riche déjà en groupes technologiques je
pense à 51 en yvelines je pense à vélizy
on peut aussi parler de courtaboeuf dans
l'essonne où deux ou de massy
nous avons là en gros le cac40
technologiques les grands assemblier les
grandes les grandes sociétés de chasse a
fait partie de paris s'associe large de
varices et une ambition c'est que si on
réussit le coeur tout où cet écosystème
va en bénéficier et va devenir plus
attractif plus dynamique et puis au
dollar c'est l'espoir bien sûr c'est que
ce soit une grande plate forme
d'innovation pour l'économie française
toute entière qu'on vienne à paris
saclay pour y trouver des idées et se
développer ou coup l'on soit sur le
territoire le but c'est d'être
compétitif avec leur as possible oui on
cette optique la ville le but c'est
d'être compétitif en europe et en europe
et dans le monde avec des grands pôles
qui sont structurés un peu de la même
manière sur les mêmes principes avec des
réalités géographiques différentes on
peut citer cambridge en royaume uni on
peut citer bien sûr l'exemple un peu
tarte à la crème mes références la
silicon valley munich en allemagne est
également un poulpe extrêmement puissant
sur deux de ce type tout ça fait que
paris saclay a pas la capacité d'être
l'un des dix grands pôles paris-saclay
pourrait rivaliser avec la silicon
valley justement alors voilà ça j'aurais
su j'aurais mieux fait de me taire donc
ce n'est pas le rêve je fais me jeter
alors que la silicon valley c'est
immense est beaucoup plus grand la
silicon valley francilienne c'est l'île
de france tout entière donc l'échelle
n'est pas la même mais les principes
d'organisation sont les mêmes et les
principes de création économique sont
finalement les mêmes et puis j'ai cité
donc l'instant 3e le troisième point
c'est un projet d'urbanisme et
d'aménagement
un territoire vous l'avez aussi bien
décrit avec ce grand pau ce grand pardon
ce grand plateau rester agricole à
l'écart de l'urbanisation très proche du
centre de la ville aujourd'hui très mal
desservi et qui était un héritage auquel
la population est attachée qui est un
élément de qualité de vie que nous
allons conserver et valoriser mais à ces
franges un urbanisme aujourd'hui souvent
un peu déficient avec du fait de
l'absence de transports en commun
structurants et donc le projet que nous
menons qui est un peu conditionne le
succès des deux autres projets c'est
celui de transformer cet urbanisme
d'accueillir de la mixité avec non
seulement des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche
des entreprises de toutes tailles mais
aussi de la ville des habitants les
étudiants des services des commerces
tout ça sur les franges de ce plateau
avec un prêt deuxième principe de
densité et de compacité il ne s'agit
plus surtout pas de s'étaler et 2 et 2
contres consommer les terrains et tout
ça grâce à un mode de transport qui est
le super métro dont on a beaucoup parlé
on verra tout à l'heure que le dossier
n'est pas encore déterminée est ce que
ce super métro ou va voir le jour on en
parlera tout à l'heure au cours de cet
entretien on va s'intéresser à la
dernière actualité en date en tout cas
pour l'établissement public paris-saclay
c'est le lancement de la consultation
pour la réalisation de logements sociaux
est destiné aux étudiants et aux
apprentis ça c'est une réalisation
concrète voilà qui peut illustrer l
cette notion d'urbanisme création de
logement que vous évoquiez un chiffre va
paraître c'est d'ailleurs le chiffre de
cette édition 300 c'est le nombre de
logements à réaliser et la consultation
qui a tout juste débuté va servir à quoi
concrètement alors c'est un point
extrêmement important il y as en
ile-de-france en général un très fort
déficit de logements étudiants et à
paris saclay particulièrement beaucoup
auraient été très peu d'étudiants
bénéficie d'une chambre dans une
résidence étudiante et c'est un c'était
un problème pour pour le dynamisme de ce
site parce que d'abord qualité de vie
des étudiants déficiente et puis ensuite
vous faiblesse de l'animation du site
puisque à 18 heures il n'y a plus
personne
et enfin sur le sud du plateau de saclay
et le week-end non plus le besoin il est
bien peu supérieur à toi à 300 il va
falloir plutôt atteindre un chiffre de 8
ce que vous citez c'est la première
tranche que nous venons effectivement de
lancer avec un appel à concurrence et
lundi dernier et qui arrivera avec
l'objectif est d'ouvrir une première
résidence en 2015 et qui arrivera avec
le même rythme que la première vague de
nouvelles écoles qui s'implante sur le
site il s'agit de se développer en
parallèle et non pas en séquences ont
fait une première étape écoles en
l'occurrence les nca de l'école de la
statistique et de l'administration
économique qui nous qui nous rejoindra
en premier puis centrale arrivera juste
après cette première tranche de
logements mais aussi on va en lancer des
projets des consultations pour des
tranches de logements familiaux et puis
des entreprises j'aurais pu les citer
aussi les premiers projets edf va
construire sont un grand centre de
recherche sur le plateau de saclay pour
accueillir 1500 salariés donc il ya ces
logements l'appel qui a été lancé la
consultation qui a été lancé ce sera un
petit peu un modèle de ce qui va ensuite
voir le jour sur ce territoire
promouvoir la mixité au coeur de
quartiers s'ouvrir sur l'espace public
favoriser la convivialité sous ce sont
des points très importants et c'est
votre rôle en tant qu'établissement
public en tant qu'aménageur de vous
assurer que ce sera bien présent sur la
réalisation c'est notre rôle en tant
qu'établissement public et c'est le
souhait des élus locaux c'est ce que
souhaitent les élus locaux les élus ne
les élus ne nous ne veulent pas un
lotissement industriel sur le la franche
du plateau bill veulent un morceau de
ville vivant et comme vous l'avez dit
mixer divers donc c'est effectivement
notre feuille de route est nôtre et
notre ambition il ya cette université
paris saclay vous avez évoqué une date
2014 pour son ouverture c'est une date
qui est maintenue pour l'instant oui oui
alors l'établissement public travaillent
la main dans la main avec le porteur de
cette université qui est la fondation de
coopération scientifique cette fondation
elle regroupe 22 établissements qui sont
déjà sur le plateau qui veulent tous
venir et elle mène ce projet de toutes
deux projets transformants de création
d'une université qui s'appellerait paris
saclay qui réunirait tous le monde
l'objectif effectivement c'est qu'elle
ait une existence juridique début 2014
pour une première rentrée en septembre
2014 par conséquent le calendrier
aujourd'hui tenues il est important de
savoir que cette ce projet a reçu le
soutien très fort vous l'avez rappelé
aussi en introduction du précédent
gouvernement et du nouveau gouvernement
il a remporté l'un des appels à projets
les plus importants des investissements
d'avenir puisqu'il est qualifié
d'initiative d'excellence ce qui lui
garantit des succès pour peu qu'il
tienne sa feuille de route dont la
création effective en 2014 et
donc alors c'était ce n'est que le début
je dis une fois qu'elle est créé ensuite
il faut créer il faut réorganiser les
diplômes il faut qu'on soit versé 22
institutions fédérer 47 mille étudiants
5700 dr andy 1500 chercheurs voilà pour
ceux qui aiment les chiffres cvs 15 % du
potentiel de recherche de la france et
pour situer un petit peu l'envergure
mais concrètement on y fera quoi dans
cette université de paris saclay
beaucoup de science beaucoup de sion
c'est à dire que c'est à la fois sa
force elle est extrêmement diverses sur
les disciplines scientifiques et les
sciences de l'ingénieur ou touche à
toutes les disciplines de base sont
couvertes un niveau un vrai niveau
d'excellence en revanche elle a moins de
l a moins de potentiel à l'exception je
dois dire de l'université versailles
saint quentin qui apporte la une une
vraie diversité un véritable intérêt à
l'ensemble sur les sciences sociales et
le droit et ce genre de chose justement
vous mentionnez l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
comment se passe les rapports avec cette
université jean-luc baissière qui est le
nouveau président de cette université
qui a succédé il ya moins d'un an à sid
lee faucheux a déclaré récemment qu'il
souhaitait pouvoir contrôler son destin
préserver les caractéristiques de son
université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et permettent de fait
compter ses propres projets l'université
de versailles saint quentin par exemple
a peur de perdre son âme de perdre ses
missions sa raison d'être son autonomie
on est au coeur du débat s'est alors
j'ai eu un peu de mal à m'exprimer sur
le sujet parce que je ne suis pas
directement en charge de ça c'est le
travail de la fondation de avec chacun
de ses 22 ans dans leur diversité avec
leur identité avec leur force de les
respecter et de l'est et de faire en
sorte que ce projet soit pour eux un
accélérateur et essentiellement positif
donc le débat a lieu pour vous
l'université saint quentin a tout
intérêt à rejoindre l'université paris 5
alors ma conviction est sage aurait pu
le dire dans la première partie c'est
que il faut que le projet marche sur ses
deux pieds et je veux dire il ya un pied
dans l'essonne et un pied dans les
yvelines et je pense que le que
l'université versailles saint quentin a
tout à gagner et à vocation à être
partie prenante de ce grand projet tous
ces projets justement ce grand projet
paris saclay a été portée par le
précédent gouvernement porté par nicolas
sarkozy plus précisément avec le
changement de gouvernement il ya
peut-être eu un moment où vous avez eu
un un doute et pour autant il ya quinze
jours jean marc ayrault le premier
ministre socialiste a confirmé qu'il y
aurait bien des investissements 850
millions en capital du plan campus les
920 en 50 millions également reçu dans
le cadre des investissements d'avenir
donc l'argent sera bien présent vous
êtes rassuré les partenaires aussi
privés eux sont rassurés ils reviennent
et ils s'intéressent à ce projet vous
avez vu le discours du premier ministre
comme nous on n'a pas vraiment douté en
réalité puisqu'on est convaincu par par
l'intérêt de ce projet
jean marc ayrault a confirmé
l'intégralité des investissements et
surtout a confirmé le sens du projet
celui que j'ai décrit un projet
économique un projet essentiel pour
l'innovation et la croissance de la
france dès cet instant il a rassuré
beaucoup il a rassuré les semble
l'ensemble des acteurs vous citez les
entreprises effectivement les
entreprises qui sont déjà dans une
dynamique pour venir à paris saclay où
ils sont déjà présentes ont aussi
entendu ce message parce que c'était un
signe fort et c'est un signe extrêmement
fort et j'ajoute les entreprises et
elles ont aussi entendu un trou une
troisième composante que vous n'avez pas
cité dans les financements c'est la
confirmation vous avez cité le plan
campus vous avez cité les l'argent pour
l'immobilier à gré du plan campus et il
ya aussi de l'argent pour la recherche
dans le cadre des investissements
d'avenir et ça ça va financer un certain
nombre de laboratoires d'excellence
d'équipements d'excellence cette fois de
l'humain et non plus des murs mais aussi
ça va financer des projets gérés
d'interface entre la recherche publique
et le développement industriel j'en cite
deux paris saclay énergie efficacité
énergétique qui associe outre des labos
publics air liquide edf total sur les
questions d'efficacité énergétique
énergétique urbaine ce genre de choses
un projet confirmé et puis le deuxième
plus près de côté yvelinois le projet bd
comme pour véhicules décarbonés et sa
mobilité même logique mais mais surtout
ce qui concerne le véhicule électrique
communicant etc il ya eu un changement
de gouvernement qui pouvait ou non
mettre un autre même si vous nous dites
que vous étiez confiant il ya aussi la
crise économique est là c'est un autre
problème fallait-il ou faut-il en tout
cas à financer le grand paris est ce une
priorité ce dossier du pari est clair
nous sommes allés poser la question à
quelques et binoy voici leurs réponses
bah oui parce que c'est des
investissements et que ça doit rapporter
à la région donc je pense que oui il
faut pas arrêter d'investir quand il ya
la crise oui je pense qu'il faut
continuer à réaliser des investissements
sur ce plateau de saclay qui permettra
non seulement à de nombreuses
entreprises de se développer sacré tout
simplement sur ce plateau de saclay mais
aussi de maintenir l'emploi voire de le
développer donc cette période de crise
on a vraiment besoin bah oui je pense
qu'il faut continuer oui
un bon levier pour développer l'activité
l'habitat
et toute la vie dans le grand saint
quentin en yvelines d'essence que ça
fait beaucoup de finances pour pour ça
mais en même temps c'est peut-être pour
améliorer est actuel des choses crise ou
pas crise toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
ils construiront ils développeront et
je pense que malgré la crise je pense
que ça peut peut-être amené du boulot
pour toi pour pas mal 46 44 shirt donc
après si c'est le but tant mieux
après toute façon derrière tout ça il ya
toujours des gens qui s'enrichiront et
mais bon ouais je pense est une bonne
chose en soi une bonne chose c'est comme
tous les financements en fait y'a un
moment donné ou à un autre pour pouvoir
générer du chiffre d'affaires au pouvoir
à générer de l'activité il faut investir
grand paris c'est bien mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya d'autres priorités mais bon en
même temps pareil on en a besoin aussi
voilà paris centre des arts quand même
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres priorités vous
allez nous dire que c'est la priorité
tout fait l'essentiel je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas juge de d autres priorités
j'apprécie beaucoup le focus me parler
par les habitants guinot sur le
l'investissement et le fait que ça va
effectivement avoir deux les fonds
d'investissement ont récolté ainsi voir
ça ça ne paraît ça me paraît très
positif alors il ya cette question dont
on parlait tout à l'heure et on va
conclure avec ça c'est cette question du
grand métro alors c'est un dossier qui a
été très long et très très très agitée
il ya eu deux projets au tout début
celui de la région ile de france
également le projet du grand paris avec
deux axes différents finalement les deux
parties ont réussi tant bien que mal à
se mettre d'accord et puis ensuite il a
fallu trouver des financements et là
avec le changement de gouvernement il ya
une autre réflexion qui s'est engagé il
ya des études qui sont en cours entre la
modernisation du réseau actuel ou alors
l'investissement et la création de
nouveaux axes les décisions seront
prises d'ici la fin de l'année au début
de l'année prochaine et là par contre il
y à 1.1 point d'inquiétude pour
l'ensemble des autres points du dossier
parce que tout est déterminé par
l'arrivée ou non de ce super métro qui
permettrait de relier toutes les
banlieues en gros au tour de paris
effectivement le métro du grand paris
c'est la colonne vertébrale du projet
dont nous nous parlons depuis dix
minutes
7 pour être plus précis ce métro du
grand paris en ce qui concerne le
territoire de paris saclay c'est ce
qu'on appelle la ligne verte qui va
d'orly jusqu'à versailles chantiers en
passant par massy le campus saint
quentin en yvelines le plateau de satory
à versailles et terminus à versailles
chantiers pourquoi c'est absolument
essentiel est calé j'ai eu quelques
aller et comment dirais-je le le cahier
des charges
c'est essentiel parce que
on va générer de l'activité on va
accueillir du monde et si on veut que ça
marche ça ne marchera que si on a un
fort report modal de la voiture
individuelle vers le transport en commun
c'est attendu par ceux qui sont déjà là
et c'est la condition de l'arrivée de
bien de bien des
biens des projets
le cahier des charges c'est rapide
fréquent est connecté au réseau
métropolitain de paris saclay n'est
surtout pas une île surtout pas la cité
des sciences la cité des étoiles hors du
monde ça ce serait l'échec il faut que
ce soit connecté aux autres pôles
économie aux autres pôles d'habitat aux
autres pour il faut que ça soit
rapidement mise en place aussi alors
c'est le détail les plus importés
exactement c'est le débat qui reste à
trancher le grand débat public que vous
avez rappelé a permis d'aboutir à cette
solution qui était qui était pas la
solution de départ à avant le départ
débat public maintenant la grande
question qui était à l'instruction en ce
moment c'est celle du phasage quelle
ligne ont fait est là nous sommes en
concurrence et tous nos amis des autres
territoires de l'île de france
chacun fait valoir ses atouts et ses
intérêts c'est bien normal
le calendrier de décision est le suivant
le gouvernement a confié une mission à
pascal auzannet qui va rendre un rapport
à la fin du mois de novembre un rapport
qu'il ferait une proposition de phasage
de la réalisation du métro à l'échelle
du grand paris et pour le convaincre
parce qu on est pris par le temps très
brièvement pour le convaincre
aujourd'hui il serait sur ce plateau
vous lui diriez quoi il faut que le
métro arrive vite calmées dirais qu'on a
ici potentiellement l'une des 15
meilleures universités du monde dans
toutes les disciplines scientifiques que
c'est un conte a déjà pardon jo a dû
commencer par là on a déjà énormément de
monde on a déjà le technocentre renault
avec ses 15 salariés on a déjà beaucoup
d'entreprises on a la capacité de faire
beaucoup mieux sur toutes les
technologies toutes les disciplines
toutes les secteurs économiques d'avenir
le développement durable
voiture électrique le la médecine la
biologie etc etc il faut pas s'arrêter
il faut saisir cette opportunité que les
acteurs se mobilisent et entreprises
universités et que on a besoin de ce
métro le plus vite possible merci donc
pascal directeur général de
l'établissement public de paris saclay
ce vaste projet et puis un toujours la
prochaine étape cruciale on en parlait
là les annonces dans les prochaines
semaines autour de l'avenir de ce super
métro va-t-il être abandonnés nous
suivons ce dossier merci d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation va s'intéresser à
présent à une commune celle de magny les
hameaux quitte le grand paris on
s'intéresse à à une ville magny les
hameaux qui poursuit son urbanisation
avec la réalisation de nouvelles
habitations réunion d'information prévue
ce mercredi soir à l'attention des
manies cohade hemani qu est-ce qui
pourront être les premiers et les
premières a déposé un dossier le point
avec johanna soudry 38 logements neufs
prévus pour 2014 sur magny les hameaux
entre la rue des écoles jean beaudin et
la rue paul cézanne la villa du hameau
verra le jour à la pointe de la chapelle
lacoste dans ce projet de type de
logement le premier donc c'est la
location location sociale pour la moitié
des logements grosso modo et puis
l'autre partie est en accession aidée ça
touche principalement des familles en
construction et ça va leur permettre
d'avoir un un prix au mètre carré pour
accéder à la propriété largement
inférieurs aux prix aujourd'hui
habituellement constatés sur la commune
le locateur accédant en bénéficient
d'une tva réduite à 5 5% au lieu de 19 6
pour cette opération
il bénéficie aussi d'une exonération
d'impôt foncier pendant 15 ans il n'a
pas à payer les appels de fonds
contrairement à une vente en état futur
d'achèvement où on paye 20 % chez
notaire 35% au niveau des fondations
donc là il est exonéré de tout versement
jusqu'à la livraison par contre pour
être éligible à ce processus
d'acquisition il faut rentrer dans des
plafonds de ressources qui sont alors je
vais prendre l'exemple d'une famille
avec un enfant de 50000 euros une et
fiscale c'est ce qui apparaît sur l'avis
d'imposition 21 logements en
location-accession et 17 en locatif
social allant du 2 au 4 pièces le
rez-de-chaussée du bâtiment hébergera
des locaux médicaux et paramédicaux sur
370 m² dans un secteur privilégié en
centre bourg on a travaillé avec des
acteurs du domaine médical de la commune
pour leur proposer ce regroupement en un
même lieu qui sera donc le nôtre notre
pôle central
pour tous les soins sur la commune de
magny les hameaux infirmières dentistes
orthophonistes et kinésithérapeutes sont
déjà prévus il ne manque plus qu'un
médecin généraliste pour lequel un appel
sera lancé prochainement en attendant
une réunion publique aura lieu le
mercredi 14 novembre à 20h30 à l'hôtel
de ville pour informer lémanique wa
présentation de projets critères
d'éligibilité planning de
commercialisation les dossiers de
candidature à récupérer des habitants
intéressés devront renvoyer leurs
dossiers avant le 28 novembre